AWAY FROM
EACH OTHER.
MATS ZUCCARE BREAKAWAY!
NICO STURM AND WILD OPEN THE
SCORING! LIES LOSE.
BJUGSTAD GRABS IT.THAT SEAM PAS
DOWN B
GOALTENDER HERE, HIN THAT PLAY.
>> YEAH, IT'S LIKE THAT CAL GET
IT.
HE'S LIKE VELCRO.
BIG NUMBER 27, OFF THE SHAFT OF
THE STICK OF THE
ROBERTSON SHOOTS AND SCORES!
AND HE'S DONE FOR THE AFTERNOON.
AN HANDS.
>> Brendan: THAT SHOT, SHARPP.
AND WE HAVE SOME PENALTIES TO
SORT OUT
HARTMAN FIRES, OFF T TW THE HEC.
FORCED DOWN LOW.
FOLILISAVE, REBOUND AND IT
WAS SPURGEON WITH  PUCK.
>> Brendan: KAPRIZOV SCORES!I T
FIRE THIS
BODY OF HIS.
HE'S HAD MANY, MANY SHIFTS TWO
MINUTES LONG.
HE WANTS THAMIE BENN FRO TRIED
THE RIGHT.
AND THERE'S THE REAC
HE HAD THREE ON FRIDAY NIGHT I
GET